as anybody who's had viral
conjunctivitis known more commonly as
pink eye can attest it's contagious it
passed on really quick like within a
week the whole house had it even so
Diego bisso and his family weren't
overly concerned so they asked their
pharmacist who told them pink eye but a
little over a week after starting
antibiotics Diego's dad's eyes were
still dark red and the 18-year-old
looked like he'd been in a fight because
it got infected as well it looked like I
was Rocky I couldn't open my eyes for
basically 5 days concern turned to worry
and after a visit to the optometrist
they were stunned to learned the goop in
their eyes came back positive for covid
so these are all cases that we had in
one day look right over here Dr Ken
mandaka says at its peak he was getting
four to five cases a day and is now
seeing a spike in new cases The Strain
is viral like traditional pink eye but
it's more aggressive than anything he's
ever seen un like the other viruses that
we've seen in the past this one is
causing a lot of inflammation of the eye
a lot of swelling of the tissue of the
eye blurred vision pain and it's causing
bleeding in the white of the eye so
instead of it being uh a pink eye in
appearance it's actually a red eye um
like a hemorrhaging type of appearance
when asked the Ontario optometrist
Association says it's certainly aware of
an increase in serious viral eye
infections and they did post some
information on their website earlier in
the season however unless they do a
broader social media campaign
information on this issue is spreading
word of mouth so optometrists telling
pharmacists what to look for this is a
patient who is obviously more advanced
we see a lot more uh hemorrhaging and
redness of the eyes the treatment for
these aggressive cases includes an eye
wash followed by prednizone drops and
symptoms can last for months some
patients were left with uh spots in
their cornea that would then lead to
glare and Halos around lights that we
now are treating for a longer term like
let's say 2 to 3 months Diego but lisimo
is getting better but some of the side
effects haven't gone away he says he's
learned a valuable lesson when it comes
to his eyes he's seeing his optometrist
Mike drite Global News Toronto